hey guys and welcome to another the
daily programmer web series and in this
one we're going to talk about a problem
called Jolly Jumper which is number
three one one on the daily program or
subreddit so let's go ahead and break
down this problem on the whiteboard okay
so for this problem you were provided
with a list of integers and what you're
trying to do is take the sequential
difference between each integer so for
instance if I do the difference between
1 & 4 in fact I should say the absolute
difference so this will give us 3 and
then again the difference between 4 & 2
will give us a difference of 2 and then
the absolute difference of 2 & 3 will
give us 1 right so the goal is given
this list can you create the same set of
integers that lead up to n minus 1 so to
kind of break that down we have n is
equal to 4 here right we have 4 numbers
so n is equal to 4 and our goal is to
create a set which is equal to 1 to n
minus 1 which is also you know 1 2 3 in
this case because n is equal to 4 so in
this particular case it turns out that
this is considered a Jolly Jumper list
right because we were able to create the
3 we were able to create the 2 and then
we're also able to create the 1 so
that's the overview of the problem now
let's try to work it out by hand
starting off you know what it is you
know we n is equal to the length of the
array minus 1 so over here you just
create a set and just let it equal to
all the numbers that lead up to n minus
1 so again 1 2 3 and then we can iterate
through this list where I is equal to 1
here and then this is I plus 1 and then
stop before you reach this 3 so again
you take I plus 1 which is going to be 4
minus I which is going to be 1 take the
absolute absolute value of that which
will give us the 3
and then once you have this value you
just go ahead and remove it from the set
here so if it exists in the set just go
ahead and remove it and then continue on
to the next number so we're increment I
by one so this is now I plus one here we
have four actually this would be 2 so we
have two and this is four which leaves
us an absolute difference of two and
again if it's in the set just go ahead
and remove it and which it is and then
start doing the process one more time
until you reach that I minus one
location so again I'll just increment I
by one so this is I now this is I plus
one and then we can take the difference
between three and two absolute value of
3 minus 2 is 1 and then remove it from
the set and then finally once you reach
the end of this array like when you're
four loops done running or wire loop of
whatever type of loop or iteration you
want to do is done just check if the set
dot length is equal to zero because if
equal to zero you know that you've
removed everything from the set and
you're okay and then if it's not then
obviously it's not a jelly jumper so you
just say it's not a jelly jumper and
that's pretty much how you solve it by
paper again loop over your set or loop
over from 1 to N to create your set then
loop over your list and then keep taking
the difference an absolute value of it
remove it from the set and then when you
reach the end of your list check if the
set is equal to 0 so let's go ahead and
implement this in JavaScript
all right so starting off the first
thing we're going to do is just define a
function called is Jolly Jumper and
that's going to take in parameter of
numbers which is just going to be an
array or list of numbers and then down
here is go ahead and call is jelly
jumper with our array of 1 4 3 & 2
I mean it's double check that that is
the right example input that we worked
down 1 4 sorry it's 1 4 2 & 3 cool
so then 2 acts
start implementing or function remember
that's the very last thing we checked I
like to do things backwards so I like to
set you know the thing that we're going
to return and then return it before I
actually start we'll work out the logic
so I work backwards into the
implementation so again we talked about
we just need to return if the set length
is equal to zero and if it is then it is
a jelly jumper so a personal is declare
set and make it equal to the empty array
and then I'll return set that length is
equal to zero which again if zero true
otherwise false so that should make
sense and now the first part of the
solution was we need to create that set
of integers from 1 to n minus 1 so we
know it n is so we say Const n is equal
to numbers dot length so we can loop
through so let is equal to 1 is less
than or equal to n minus 1 I plus plus
loop through from 1 to n minus 1 and
then just go ahead and push that number
into the set so it's going to push 1 2 &
3 into the set in this example and I can
just go ahead and print out set here so
we can visualize that on line 9 so it
pushes 1 2 & 3 and then we're good to go
and then the next step of the algorithm
remember is we need to loop through the
numbers take the absolute difference
between the numbers and remove them one
by one from the set if we found
something so I'll go ahead and just do
another loop so for let a equal zero I
less than the numbers length minus 1 and
remember we don't want to go out of
bounds because we're taking we're going
to check I we're also going to check I
plus 1 so we need to make sure numbers
that length minus 1 is our condition so
that we will go out of bound when they
array so then in this loop we can say
Const a is equal the numbers of I
constant B is equal in numbers of I plus
1 I'll just go ahead and pick duck a and
B here so we can kind of visualize
what's going on so again in the first
iteration a is 1 B is 4 x ik constant if
is equal to math of absolute value of a
minus B print that out so we get 3 2 1
so again take a step back we get the
first number get the second number we
take the difference and we take the mass
of the absolute value of that difference
and now we just need to remove it from
the set if it exists in the set so I can
say if set index of diff is not equal to
negative one so it does exist in the set
I'm going to say set that splice set the
index of diff and then remove that one
element from the array and if you're not
familiar with line 19 that's pretty much
how you given an array remove a
particular number from that array so now
at this point I can just go ahead print
out set again and we see that it removes
the three it removes the two and it
removes the one so this is going to
return true for us down here let's go
ahead and remove all these little
annotations and console logs so we have
a clean function to look at so that
should make sense and then we remove
let's say the three this should be false
right because 1 minus 4 gives us 3 and
then 4 minus 2 gives us 2 but we're
really looking for one and two and I'll
just go ahead and again write that out
so I can say what is the value of set
here and at the end so the first
iteration we get a 3 it tries to remove
3 from the set that doesn't exist
because remember we're looping
from 1 to n minus 1 and n is equal to 3
in this case so up here if I were to
print out set the set is 1 and 2 but we
get 3 and 2 which means that this is not
a jelly jumper set yeah so that wraps
with the whole jelly jumper number I
think is 3 1 1 challenge of there's
probably some better ways to do this
maybe there's like a reduced function
you can use for creating this or just
more concise code this is my first
implementation so this is basically how
you do it off the top of my head again
if you liked this video give us a like
and then be sure to subscribe to free
code camp below all right
thanks for watching